foreign
happy Friday I'm Jack Van Horn from the
University of Virginia and I am very
proud to welcome you to this edition of
our 2022-2023 foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series this lecture
series is supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences
since 2016 the foundations of biomedical
data science seminar Series has focused
on the use of data science methodologies
artificial intelligence deep learning
and statistical modeling as they pertain
to different themes in the biomedical
and Health Sciences this year's theme is
data science and the public health
consequences of the covid-19 pandemic
where each Friday we enjoy presentations
from leading thinkers about the issues
the promise the opportunities and the
hurdles associated with understanding
the secondary health effects of covet
19.
these include delayed Health checkups
and treatments mental health drug abuse
increased obesity and the long lingering
health effects associated with the SARS
covid-19 virus
participants selected in our biomedical
data science Innovation lab program will
leverage these presentations as vital
material for our culminating in-person
Grant project development Workshop to be
held at the lodge at St Edwards Park in
Seattle Washington in June of 2023.
I am delighted to welcome our speaker
today Dr Jason Shu from the Department
of statistical science at Duke
University Jason is an assistant
professor in the department of
statistical science with a secondary
appointment by courtesy in biostatistics
and bioinformatics prior to joining The
Faculty at Duke
Jason worked at the University of
California Los Angeles with support from
the NSF mathematical sciences and
postdoctoral research Fellowship he
completed his PhD in statistics at the
University of Washington in Seattle
where his work was funded by
and ndseg fellowship and Dr Shu grew up
in Tucson where he received his BS in
mathematics from the University of
Arizona in 2012. in continuing with our
biomedical data science seminar series
theme today's lecture is entitled
likelihood based methods for fitting
stochastic epidemic models to noisy data
due to noisy data observational data or
non-linear Dynamics even simple
stochastic epidemic models such as the
sir model present significant challenges
for inferences
as a result likelihood-based inference
is typically considered Out Of Reach In
The Presence of missing data and
practitioners often resort to simulation
methods or approximations that make bias
conclusions and reduce interpretability
motivated by a number of these
challenges Jason is going to share with
us today how a data augmented approach
successfully learns interpretable
epidemic parameters and scales to handle
large realistic data settings
efficiently as always we are streaming
this lecture live and for recording via
YouTube If you are watching on YouTube
thank you for joining us also
our specially selected
2022-23-23 biomedical data science
Innovation lab participants and alumni
are encouraged to submit any questions
they have by the chat feature in their
Zoom sessions I will synthesize these
questions and ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture and with that welcome Jason we
are so excited to hear from you
thank you so much Jack for the
introduction and thank you all for being
here and for the invitation to speak in
this great series
um my talk as you might be able to tell
from the title is going to be biased
toward statistical inference I'm a
statistician and um some of the work is
kind of technical in nature it's
methodological but I'm really excited to
talk about it with such a broad audience
coming from all sorts of different
backgrounds which as we've seen is so
important to address everything since
this pandemic
um and a lot of these challenges kind of
go back of course the long mathematical
tradition for modeling epidemics
um a lot of this work has been around
since before the pandemic but also the
sort of realizations we've encountered
with the data that have come up and the
sort of new ways we can study Dynamics
as a disease moves through a population
has spurred a lot of new development for
these methods alongside computational
developments in the modern in the modern
world so without further Ado I'll go
ahead and get started on my slides um I
do want to say again it's I try to make
some of the technical stuff there for
concreteness but also I try to make it
so that the overall theme will hopefully
come through even without understanding
all of the technical details and I'm
always happy to take questions of course
for anything that's not clear
so uh of course this is kind of about
epidemic models and we know that this is
related to the pandemic for this year's
theme but I just want to emphasize that
in many disciplines uh Beyond just sort
of the spread of disease uh for instance
computer scientists might need to look
at how ideas or information or memes
spread across a network and of course
economists might want to look at how
Behavior spreads among individuals in
some kind of community but in many of
these disciplines we want to understand
the spread of something like
disease-like
and uh in in my own view on on these
models because there's such a great
literature from so many different
disciplines uh we think that's at least
some of the things we want our models to
reflect is the mechanics of how this
disease or contagion is spreading
um I'm a statistician so I'm biased
toward wanting some kind of Randomness
so I'm I'm going to be talking about
stochastic models where not everything
is predetermined by the specifics of the
rules you specify and the parameters but
there is some Randomness in how the
process evolves and uh one thing that
I'll mention in this talk is that we'd
like to account for some structure and
rates of contacts in the population and
that's something that's not always done
in sort of uh many of these studies
today even though we know that these
rates are going to have a big effect on
how the disease spreads
and so why don't people account for all
of these pretty simple things all the
time well basically doing sort of
rigorous inference can be a challenging
math problem or even when the math is
known it can be a challenging Computing
problem and this is true even in some of
the simplest models that many of you
have heard of so what I'm talking about
today is something called Data
augmentation which is not a new idea
it's been around for a long time and
even in the 90s people have studied some
of these simple models under this
perspective but there are a lot of
computational limitations to the general
idea that we're hoping to revisit and
revive and in particular are are
revisiting of this approach will
hopefully be very complementary to the
dominant ways that people look at
stochastic models of disease which
relies on rather intensive simulation as
we'll see
so let's talk about these epidemic
models uh first the compartmental models
of infection such as Sir this is what
Jack mentioned in my abstract this is
going to be the focus of the kinds of
model we talk about today and this goes
back almost 100 years ago to the work of
sir kermack and mckendrick and it
describes how a disease process moves
between groups in a population where
those individuals are grouped by disease
status
so in the simplest case you have
susceptible people who are being
infected by some population rate here it
looks like beta times s times I and then
those people are gonna when they become
infected they move to the eye
compartment which is the Infectious
individuals and then those individuals
will recover or be removed because of
death or something like that from the
population at some other rate which
looks like it's gamma times the
Infectious population
so in this very simple model there's
just two parameters beta and gamma and
classically in their work and they've
also described General versions even in
that original paper and there are many
variations on such models but these
compartmental models they were typically
proposed and still mostly studied today
under uh what we'll call a deterministic
dynamical system okay so when I say ode
I mean that this set of equations is
they're called Ordinary differential
equations and that's how that describes
the disease flow
but these equations just tell you
basically curves that are preordained
once you give me beta and S beta and
gamma and the populations
so instead what we want to talk about
today is basically the analogous model
but it's going to be a stochastic or
random version of those Dynamics okay
and so in this case I'm basically going
to replace that set of differential
equations without going into too much
detail yet by uh some random processes
in particular this is going to be what's
called a continuous time markup chain
now in this model when I have a
realization of the curve like this it's
actually not smooth which is what they
would look like under that first model I
showed you rather the the population can
go you know there can be little jumps
depending on these random events that
are occurring and I would say that the
parameters under this model can also be
more interpretable in addition to having
Randomness that helps us estimate the
uncertainty in our parameters so for
instance a lot of Public Health
officials are very interested in
estimating things like basic
reproductive numbers and oftentimes in
words such a quantity is defined as the
average number of secondary infections
caused by an infectious person and so
you know that that can be somewhat vague
in a deterministic model even though
there are equations to get at that it
doesn't always align with most Layman's
notion of the word average right which
is often a statistical average like you
take a lot of numbers and you average it
so in this case if I have random
variables first of all this quantity is
directly related to the parameters the
interpretable parameters I want to
estimate from the data and for they're
more because it's a stochastic model I
really know what this notion of average
means in an intuitive way
one other thing I want to mention is
when we write down these models with
equations such as this it is assuming
already under the hood that there's
random mixing going on which means that
all the susceptibles and infectious
people are bumping at each other
uniformly and at a constant rate so
there's no structure in the population
it your behavior doesn't change
depending on your disease status and
that might not be very desirable for uh
studying outbreaks especially things
like covet when the behavioral contact
patterns are changing very much
throughout the pandemic with different
policies and different behaviors
so this this talk we're not actually
going to talk about covet data per se
we're going to be motivated by a mobile
health study that was collected by a
colleague Allison Aiello in a study
called xflute and so in this study
there's a bluetooth app that
participants were given that actually
pings when two participants are near
enough and then stops pinging when
they're far and this is happening in
real time so over the course of the
study we can actually observe these
contact networks between individuals and
as you see just plotting some of the raw
data at some of the weeks we see that
certainly it's not a complete Network
which means not all edges are present so
of course not everybody is bumping into
everybody else at a constant rate in
fact it's kind of sparse in terms of the
density and so we would like to for
instance not only enable this rigorous
statistical inference but also make
these models more realistic by
incorporating such information
and so naturally one might be interested
in Transmission in such a network right
when we talk about this well-mixed
setting where everyone's bumping into
everyone one way to kind of represent
this in some mathematical object is
let's say we had a population of only
five people we're going to represent
this by a complete graph which means
everybody has the potential to interact
with everyone else that's what the edges
denote but of course if we observe
Network information or so from for
instance mobile data we might know that
person one was only in potential contact
with person two three and four and so
therefore the infection could only have
spread that way if a person one was
infectious similarly if you wanted to do
contact tracing or something and person
five later got infected at this time you
might know that it could not have been
one that was the source if you have this
kind of data and of course there's a lot
of recent growing interest in this
setting
but even before getting to that setting
what I want to claim is when you want to
do a lot of the traditional approaches
that are kind of fully rigorous in
statistical inference uh even that
simple model that I plotted on the first
few slides is very difficult to to fit
exactly okay and so I'm going to try to
motivate why that is in a little more
technical detail soon but first let's
talk about what people do instead
because I know that there are a lot of
papers out there and all sorts of
disciplines that say we have this sir
model this complicated model and then we
learn it from data
so when people say this I'd say most of
the time especially if it's a model with
a lot of bells and whistles it's quite
common that they're actually doing the
inference or the simulation or the model
fitting under some kind of approximation
to the fully stochastic model anyway of
course you could have a deterministic
model but because those pre-ordained
curves will never match the data exactly
they will add some statistical noise
Distribution on top of that so it's a
mixture of something that's
deterministic plus Randomness that's not
related to the process itself and that
might be a little bit subtle
there are also other stochastic process
approximations so there are other random
processes but you might need to simplify
the Dynamics you might have it evolve
discreetly stepwise through time instead
of naturally in a continuous way or you
might have an opposite thing where
instead of keeping track of exact
populations you treat everything as a
continuous number when you have a large
population these are called diffusion
approximations there's all sorts of
approximations out there so I think it's
really important to know when you're
doing inference under what model because
even though they're often called the
same things like sir or its variants
these little approximations can make big
differences in bias your inference
similarly when you actually want to fit
these stochastic models exactly the
model is the sort of predominant method
for doing inference is is often
simulation based so there are things
like sequential Monte Carlo things
called particle filtering and they rely
on simulating many realizations of the
data from the model itself and seeing
basically how well they match and then
the ones that match well you upgrade
those parameters this is a very
cartoonish way to describe it but the
idea is that these methods are actually
very flexible very powerful but they're
pretty hard to implement and they kind
of can work on a case-by-case basis when
you have a data set where it just
happens not to work well it's something
called either poor mixing it can become
degenerate and give you a solution
that's just not interpretable at all and
finally because they're so intensive
without really large scale computational
resources it's hard to do this on on
large data sets okay so what we'll focus
on is instead of very classical thing in
statistics where we make use of the
likelihood directly to fit these models
and we want to take into account all
these aspects of these models that I've
just reviewed
okay so here's a little bit of technical
detail and I hope I just want to
illustrate the high level Point um but
give some concreteness so I've mentioned
that in the stochastic case we have
these models being a class of continuous
time Markov chains and that means that
the randomness comes from the fact that
we have rates of things going on in this
case infections and recoveries or maybe
more like contact rates and then we wait
a random variable amount of time until
one of these events happens and then the
state jumps to a new process and in a
Markov process that waiting time is
something called exponential and when we
have such a nice distribute this nice
distribution has a lot of properties
that makes things mathematically elegant
so the likelihood of the process which
describes how well a given set of
parameters explain the data we observe
can be written down in a reasonably
manageable form okay it has this
memorylessness property so I'm not going
to give a full overview of this but for
those of you who understand this I hope
this gives more concreteness
so this is such a nice form you know if
you were a statistic student even in
early years of your education you would
know that In classical approaches if
this quantity called the likelihood is
telling me how well a given set of
parameters Theta supports my data then
to look for inferring the most likely
parameters it would make sense to try to
maximize this quantity with respect to
those parameters so using some pretty
simple calculus I can maximize this and
find things called the maximum likely
estimators or if I want to take a
Bayesian approach which we'll focus on
later I can do something called
specifying conjugate priors which means
updating my parameters given the data
has a really nice form that's
computationally one line for a computer
okay so we want to maximize this
likelihood and so far the likelihood I
wrote down for any continuous time
Markov chain which should include the
processes I'll talk about is actually
really straightforward what we need is
we see that these quantities are
functions of the total number of each
type of event and the total time the
process spends in each kind of state it
has
so where is the difficulty arising you
know why is this talk not over well
again the challenges that in real life
when we study epidemics and collect
observational data from surveillance
studies and things like that we're
almost never going to observe all of
these quantities that inform these two
uh terms that we need to compute these
estimators just as an example let's say
we have incidence data which is a focus
of this talk so every week maybe this
interval is describing one week I've
observed four new infections well to
compute those quantities for instance
I'll need to know the Infectious
population and if I don't know it if I'm
only getting data on new infections it
could have started with two infectious
people and given the same number of
recoveries ended with two infectious
people that week or it could have
started with more infectious people and
if there was only one recovery
throughout the week I'd have seven here
and not only do the different numbers of
infectious populations account for the
likelihood but even if I change these
times slightly for these four events
that will also change the likelihood and
so you could imagine if I can think
about put any number of possible events
and Computing all their probabilities
and changing their time slightly there's
actually an infinite number of such step
function looking objects these
continuous paths that are consistent
with my observed data right I can have
infinitely many such shapes not just
these two that are consistent with the
fact that there were four new infections
and so mathematically this becomes a
hard problem as you might imagine you
have to integrate over all of that and
account for their probabilities
so our goal is to develop a framework
that can do so precisely okay so we want
to do inference based on that exact
likelihood even though we have that
missing data and we would also like to
not only do this for sir but to expand
it to relax some of the assumptions and
make it more realistic for the kind of
data we have today
okay so I know I spend a lot of time on
the intro but I really think that a lot
of my goal on these kinds of talks is
really to motivate the kinds of
challenges that some people are either
not even aware they're lurking when we
fit these models or for those of us who
are in technical Fields might be excited
to make further contributions on in
terms of the inference
so here we have a little bit of notation
for sure because the approach to to deal
with the missing data is something
called Data augmentation so I want to
describe it at a high level
I've already described that if I work
with the data I observe somehow there's
an integral in the background I need to
somehow account for all the missing data
all those possible paths each have their
own probabilities under that likelihood
and the likelihood if I have the whole
path is the thing that I've shown do we
have a nice equation for but the
likelihood of my observed data somehow
needs to average over all of those
possible paths weighted by their
possible probabilities that can be a
really hard problem
but if I don't know how to compute this
red term one thing we can do is it's
sort of technical but statisticians have
a well-used class of approaches called
Markov chain Monte Carlo that makes use
of a likelihood to draw samples from the
posterior distribution
and basically flipping this term around
via Bayes Rule now if I have access to
this blue term that's the part that I
said even sort of young students in our
department can do calculus and deal with
then we can maybe design a sampler that
targets the distribution of both the
unobserved states Z as well as the
parameters we care about so Theta
denotes all the parameters whether it's
beta the transmission rate gamma the
recovery rate additional things having
to do with contacts Etc
and if I can draw latent variables to
explore the possible values of Z and
learn about their probabilities by
targeting this Bayesian posterior
distribution via something called mcmc
then now I can deal with the marginal
distribution or the distribution I cared
about in the first place which is what
is the probability of those parameters
given just the observed data
so this is something I don't have time
to explain in one lecture but this is
well known which is if you have this
approach that somehow is generating
samples of jointly your parameters you
care about and the missing data well
once you want to marginalize or get rid
of the missing data and just look at the
parameters given that posterior
distribution uh you know you're drawing
them in pairs Theta 1 Z1 Theta 2 Z2 you
can just ignore the Z component so think
about putting them in a table and just
covering your eye and looking at the
thetas that is now a valid draw from the
posterior we care about from the
distribution the probabilities of the
parameters given are observed data
so now I'll describe one implementation
of the strategy for that Network case in
a paper that's again with my
collaborators Alison aiella who is now
at Columbia biostat and Alex wolfoski
who is in my department as well as a
phenomenal graduate student who's since
graduated fan
okay so this is going to be an instance
of the strategy I've described
now um the network process is actually
going to be very simple like I said we
choose to we want to remove the
assumption that this contact Network
between individuals which of course will
have more than five is not just the
complete graph at all points it's in
fact something that depends on the
observed links from our mobile Health
Data and so each time we'll we'll
observe some links which can be encoded
in what's called an adjacency Matrix
which means there's a one every time
there's a link between person I and J so
I see a link between person one and two
so there's a one here there's also a
link between person one and three and
one and four but we don't see a link
between person one and five similarly
person two is only attached to person
one at this time so they're just the one
in his row and zeros elsewhere
now this network is going to be changing
over time right we're relaxing the
assumption that it's complete and fixed
so this itself will also be some Markov
process that's changing between zeros
and ones in its entries but what we'd
like is that well these dynamics of how
people interact will depend on the
disease status right you might if you're
a one you're interacting with somebody
but now your friend is sick maybe you're
more likely to become a zero which is to
stop interacting with them than if they
were healthy and similarly if you're
sick and you have a moral conscious you
you might uh you might stop interacting
with a higher rate than if you weren't
sick
so let's define a similar process where
if you are not linked there's some rate
of connecting called Alpha and the
subscripts the note the disease statuses
of these individuals that you'll start
interacting and similarly there's some
rate for instance in an exponential
distribution with
Omega you'll wait that long but
probabilistically before you break your
link uh we'll denote Omega the links the
link break rates
this will be superimposed on top of the
same disease process that people have
studied for a long time but we see how
it generalizes the network being
complete so whenever there is an edge
with rate beta which is that same beta
transmission rate in the classical sir
model you'll have i infecting j right
similarly there's a competing rate maybe
gamma like the the waiting time is is
first and then person I would recover
before infecting person J so now I is
recovered and J remains susceptible
maybe they'll have other neighbors that
can infect them or maybe they're safe
so we see if you can imagine that if you
had a complete Network then the total
number of eyes infected people that are
in contact with Jays when all edges in
the network are present is actually s
times I If s is the total susceptible
population and I is the total infectious
population and that's where the beta
times s times I and the classical model
comes from but we're actually trying to
replace that so we see that at the
individual level you have infections
recoveries and different kinds of Link
events on all potential edges in the
network so there's a lot of links but
they share these rates
now if we're assuming that sort of we're
just going to decrease the number of
parameters by saying well you know the
probability that two healthy people
interact whether they're already
recovered or whether susceptible doesn't
really make a difference
so when we superimpose all of these
things together at the population level
we have infection rates occurring at
this is sort of poor notation but it's
beta times s i of T so s i of T is the
number of s i edges which in the
complete graph is s of T times I of T so
this is slightly different from that
and this is changing all the time
recovery is occurring at a certain rate
that's identical to the original process
because individuals are independently
recovering that's not really dependent
on their social network and then of
course there's all these linked terms
that we need to take a lot of
Bookkeeping on the number of different
types of pairs
but overall the Dynamics are very
tractable it's still going to belong in
this nice mathematical class of
continuous time markup chains and if I
wrote down the likelihood even though
there's tons of jargon in terms of the
notation you can trust that it's just as
nice of a mathematical form that's
manageable basically there are these
there's these kinds of rates under these
kinds of waiting times and all of these
things are computable you can do the
nice calculus here it's the same simple
form but with more quantities and more
notation
okay
so just to validate the model we ran
simulation studies where again like you
you want to be able to recover the
parameters under the model if that
generated your data so in these studies
we simulate data from our model and we
let the we let the simulation go as we
have more and more events so we think
that with more and more data the more
events we observe the better our
estimates should be and so holding out
the events and and using our estimators
the sort of the forms we've derived
um for each of these rates as the
pandemic simulated pandemic goes on we
do see that with more and more data
empirically these estimates are becoming
consistent they're getting around the
ground truth that we simulated them from
which is the black lines and so this is
just showing four repeats but of course
we did much more simulations in the
tables in the paper which you can check
out if you're curious
and so let's talk really briefly about
the actual application to the xflu data
set right so we've we validated the
likelihood we have a lot more simulation
studies to look at things like
frequentis properties are the confidence
intervals correctly doing the nominal
coverage and that's all in the paper and
I'll give you references at the end
but let's now talk about how how can we
use this nice tractable likelihood in
the more challenging setting I've been
motivating this whole time right what
I'm saying here is we still have the
nice closed form Solutions at the
beginning of the talk and if I simulate
the epidemic I can look at the event
times and the dwell times the things I
need but in more
notation here and I can estimate things
correctly so basically this checks that
our formulas are correct but again I
need to somehow apply this to the case
where I have missing data where I get to
use this data augmented strategy in
accounting for the missing data by
moving around latent variables for the
unobserved quantities and proposing them
efficiently to explore the space of
unobserved quantities effectively
so in our problem setting for instance
in the setting that this exclude study
motivates you might have weekly health
status reports so of course this is not
monitored continuously in time every
week we'll have sort of recovery reports
from surveys on when these studied
participants feel better or when they're
sick
and we do continuously observe the
network which is really nice right
because of those cell phones in the
study that part we don't have missing
data on their in their Link in creations
and deletions
but we do have this data split up by
weeks and so we know for instance in the
elf week there are some L new recoveries
but we need to know the times of these
events just like that figure I showed
you or else we don't know the
likelihoods um these nice blue
quantities that we used for this
simulation study so now we need to do
something augmented we're not only
estimating beta and gamma and Omega and
Alphas but we're also estimating all of
these unknown times R which is a much
more High dimensional problem right you
had a couple parameters and a nice model
and now you have a new variable for each
person
furthermore the sort of structure of
this latent space is quite constrained
right it needs to obey the Dynamics of
the process but it also needs to obey
all the constraints from that observed
Network right you can't have somebody
recover too soon if later their only
link gets infected because that person
needs some explainable infector
so you can imagine it's kind of the
structure of this problem is rather
tricky but it's also a fascinating math
problem and so how does data augmented
mcmc look there's really two steps in
terms of describing the algorithm as a
high level so it looks easier than it is
the first is the data augmentation step
I mean we have these observed data but
each one has a couple of missing
variables and we need to propose new
configurations you know we don't know
when the recovery times are let's
propose different ones move the
potential times around and based on the
likelihoods the probabilities of these
configurations learn things jointly with
the data
so we need to be able to propose those
recovery times and compute their
probabilities under those current
parameters as well as all the
constraints by our data
now given the current setting of
potential recovery times and we can now
update the parameters and this kind of
step is going to be nice this is again
the whole idea of having a nice model
with a good well-behaved likelihood
function when all the data are observed
is because when I fixed a potential
configuration of the unobserved data in
this completed setting I can then do a
nice parameter update I can learn beta
and gamma and everything else well so
we're going to alternate between
proposing things that we don't have by
Computing the missing data in some sense
and then using all that information to
have a nice mathematical object that we
can use to learn the parameters okay and
so there's a lot of theory on why this
is actually doing exact inference under
the model
I was moving away from these biased
approximations which again are very
effective they're very useful but you
could imagine at the very least that
this becomes feasible it actually serves
for the first time as a baseline where
you can you can use a faster you know
fancier method um but if you don't have
guarantees on that method you can
compare how well it's doing in a setting
uh with this method and then if it's
doing well you can feel more confident
in using it for settings where this
might be difficult
okay so here's the high level idea again
there's too much notation but I hope
I've explained the idea and then the
first step like I said is the by far the
harder step you have to propose these
things I've alluded to the fact that
they need to respect all the constraints
from the network and so I'm actually not
going to go into this slide what I want
to do is just emphasize the result which
is this really was the work of that
phenomenal graduate student a fan was
able to derive a step that not only
moves around those unknown times in a
way that's guaranteed to respect the
data because you could imagine you know
you can have a simple algorithm that
says oh well this person recovered too
soon and there's a contradiction so I
now need to add some time to their
recovery when you when you have a clunky
algorithm that you know just moves
things around until all the constraints
are satisfied at the end of the day the
probability of all the things you chose
to do in those steps with all these if
statements can be a messy thing to work
with instead the step that we have for
step one is going to respect all the
constraints but actually be what's
called a conditional draw off from its
distribution so what we mean is that the
way that the algorithm proposes these
missing values is exactly according to
the probabilities they should be
distributed under so that we get to
accept every proposal we don't have to
reject some because the probability was
too low so that's something again quite
subtle but if you work on Markov chain
Monte Carlo you'll immediately recognize
sort of the the advantages to having
something that's what's called a Gib
step or a conditional draw from a
probability of distribution given
everything else
so I hope it won't get any more
technical than that but I hope the high
level idea makes sense for those of you
who aren't technical
so what I mean like I said is once you
have the proposed missing data all of
the updates for the parameters are
really really nice so in this case you
know the formulas look kind of crazy but
this is one line in a computer an r and
when you have functions like this
sampling from a known distribution like
a gamma function it's super easy super
fast and so we're very happy with these
kinds of estimates every time they have
a sampler
and so the sampler alternates like this
and tends to perform quite well
so I don't want to talk too much about
the real data because uh what I really
really want to focus on in this talk is
just you know giving an overview of the
methodology but we should at least you
know convince you that this was able to
work well on the motivating example so
in this case we have a study on college
campus of flu-like transmissions and uh
it's quite complicated because we have
about 600 students over 10 weeks there's
a little break in the middle we have
tons of network events observed and we
definitely observe low Network density
in the Raw data which motivates the fact
that we need to relax those well-mixed
Assumption of these novels
now just going on to the to the analysis
we were able to run that data augmented
mcmc and so for the first time on this
data set we were able to do rigorous
statistical inference on jointly
estimating all the parameters right so
we have the likelihood of this exact
model and then we're able to do not only
estimation so here we're reporting the
posterior means of all the parameters
but we also have you know the
corresponding uncertainty quantification
so right now I happen to be reporting
the 2.5 to 97.5 uh quantiles so in this
case 95 posterior credible intervals
um and again the numbers might not mean
too much for you this is some study of
dynamics of an outbreak on a college
campus but uh you know it's it's really
for the first time the methodology is
saying that here's estimates jointly
um and in a fully stochastic model that
incorporates the Dynamics of the network
and not only that but if you believe
that this is your model right which is a
big if this is something that's really
important if you believe that this is
your model then the uncertainty
estimation coming out of it is exact
right so this is exactly the way to
quantify how much Faith you should have
in your parameter estimates if you
believe in the model
and there's a whole other can of worms
there which the likelihood actually
really helps with so if you don't know
whether this is the model because
there's overall likelihood scores of
these best estimates of the parameters
you can do all sorts of things that are
rigorous that are steeped in information
theoretic criteria to do model selection
to ask yourself is this model sufficient
to explain the data or for instance on
the other hand is it too rich did I put
in too much stuff in the model and I'm
at risk of overfitting so that my
predictions are unstable so all of these
things statisticians are very aware of
that we really like to make you know
predictions to make inferences and to
draw conclusions from the data in a
principled manner a lot of these things
revolve around this likelihood function
so the purpose of this is to really
motivate that we can do likelihood-based
inference for these models even though a
lot of people have sort of written that
approach off as interactable
and just to actually talk about the
estimates a little bit you know we do
have sort of sensical estimates based on
the uh the pilot studies that didn't
have statistics for for all of these
parameters they're not super easy to
interpret uh like I mean they're
interpretable but it's not easy to look
at the table because of scaling for
instance this rate looks so high but
it's because there are much more links
between healthy people than others you
know most of the people are linked but
healthy
but but it does just to sort of
interpret some of these things there's a
strong internal force of infection
because we do have an external infection
rate which details are in the paper uh
and there's slow transmission across the
campus with quick recovery and in
general the contacts were very short and
the context being short could have been
estimated independently of course from
the data but now we're having the
Dynamics of that affect our estimates of
the parameters again if we did not
account for that these parameter
estimates could be very biased which
we've seen in the paper as well and not
included in these slides
great
so in this first paper you know the one
I've been focusing on for the core of
this talk we've already seen that we can
design these generative models in the
tradition of these compartmental models
but also relax some of these maybe
stringent assumptions such as well
mixing and in this case it describes the
interplay between the disease process
and the contact process right not only
are we seeing how the disease progresses
conditional on a network but also how
does the Network's rates change
conditional on the current disease
status of those people so it's really
interweaving and um of course
statistically the whole idea is to
enable exact inference so that if you
believe in a certain model you can you
can know that your estimates are are
correct and the uncertainty more
importantly is correct but furthermore
if you don't know which model to choose
you can have this criteria to uh to
select models within a class
now I would say there's still a lot of
limitations so this is one thing I want
to talk about for the remainder of this
talk of course you know we have certain
mathematical assumptions right now we
were talking about Markov models where
there's an exponential recovery time and
exponential time for infectiousness and
many people have observed that this is
not true for many diseases it's not a
good fit right so right now we're trying
to see well given that we've Revisited
this augmented approach for posterior
inference for Bayesian inference how can
we build upon this Foundation to expand
the class of model complexity model
realism so that not only is the
inference correct under the model but we
can do this for more and more models
that people want to investigate
so just a couple previews here we have
some new work that not only is going to
deal with the stuff in missing recovery
times but also looks at when you don't
even have any information on the
infection times of individuals and that
actually makes the problem much harder
because these things are not only very
high dimensional but quite correlated
with one another in this same line of
work we're going to be able to
accommodate the semi-markov case where
these times are not necessarily
exponentially distributed so for those
of us who do mathematics you might be
aware that this is this is a big Leap
Forward because it really changes the
whole structure of these likelihoods and
everything else
um and again this stuff has been
investigated in the past but has really
been limited to small outbreaks and
requires a lot of compute time whereas
our current uh
directions using this data augmented
approach and these really nice proposal
densities that we've engineered uh is
able to do this inference on a single
laptop like a you know regular MacBook
for really large outbreaks in just
minutes and so this is a hugely compared
to a lot of the existing methodologies
in terms of computational time and of
course some of the existing
methodologies the dominant approaches
for stochastic models are much more
flexible than what we have for now but
like I said we're building upon this
Foundation very excited for these future
directions
I'll probably skip this slide but it's
trying to tell you that to design these
nice effective proposals we really need
to just come up with similar stochastic
processes with slightly simpler dynamics
that are more mathematically trackable
and you know unlike these other
approximation approaches which then does
inference under that simpler process we
can use these processes to explore the
latent variables doing step one in the
data augmented approach but then correct
their likelihoods so that at the end of
the day we're actually doing inference
under the exact process the original one
that we posited
when we have such proposals the uh the
step one the kind of latent variable
update can be really really nice you can
look at that pseudo code here you can
generate the entire epidemic in terms of
the infection times and removal times
and basically two joint lines of code so
you don't need to do things sequentially
for those of you who simulate epidemics
and know how intensive that can be you
can really place them down because of
the sort of decoupled dynamics of these
similar processes so again this is just
a preview I don't expect to cover two
things in technical detail on talk
um but is the the directions we're
building upon uh from from that
these approximations even when you only
have let me see on the caption you only
have five observation times throughout a
whole epidemic that dies out and we see
that the approximations are quite far
from the original process in Gray but as
you increase the number of observations
to even just 10 you see that it's much
more faithful it's almost looking like
the exact original process and when you
have more and more observations which of
course is more and more possible these
days and the data we collect it's
basically uh identical Dynamics as the
target process so it's really really
promising and I'm really excited to
share that work uh soon as it keeps
coming out
we've also applied that kind of work to
real data and so many of you who study
disease are familiar with this uh this
Ebola pandemic in Western Africa some
years ago and many of the studies for
instance the World Health Organization
based a lot of their estimates on these
deterministic models and even there they
had to do a couple rather heuristic
parametrizations of the transmission
rates and things like that whereas we
can finally apply this completely
stochastic approach to analyze data of
this scale in just a couple of minutes
on one laptop again so this is this is a
big breakthrough in terms of computation
and of course we really are just
Reviving classical ideas that do exact
inference that have been around for a
while but with a new modern lens for the
kind of data and Computing resources we
have today and the sort of new advances
in Bayesian statistical methodology
so sort of a lot of exciting things and
analyzing all sorts of partially
observed epidemic data
okay so I'll wrap up pretty soon here I
just want to close by saying that a
fully stochastic modeling has a lot of
advantages right I kind of delved right
into this but why do we care about the
stochastic model approach I would say
that they're a little more interpretable
than these deterministic models right
when you have things like the
probability of an outbreak that that has
meaning under the parameters in a
stochastic model where in a
deterministic model you you just have
curves dictating its size but it's it's
already going to have an outbreak which
is a strange thing to have when you're
doing inference and predictions
the uncertainty quantification is more
interpretable and also you know
coincides with the estimation when we
have likelihood-based inference and
eventually when we build out this
framework to have richer models that are
more more realistic to describe all the
data we have this will lead to very
reliable forecasting and decision making
right we can quantify whether we're
overfitting we can quantify how well
we're capturing the data and the
uncertainty quantification the
confidence or credible intervals coming
out of the inference are trustworthy
Again The Continuous time Markov chain
framework we focused on here is is very
classical for mathematicians and the
long line of modeling alongside
epidemiologists but it's extensible in
many open directions we've already been
relaxing some of these distributional
assumptions to make this super flexible
and in one example here we've relaxed
the while mixing assumption to
incorporate networks but we're also
working to incorporate spatial data all
sorts of different sources from
phylogenetic information and again like
from a likelihood based approach there
are ways to to integrate these things
naturally
there's still a lot of open directions
and things we're working toward as well
as things that we'd like other people to
work towards so right now we haven't
really dealt with the case which is very
natural from a data perspective they
have multiple strains uh multiple
compartments like not just in terms of
disease status but in strata of the
population we have been working already
on different individual level covariates
to add more heterogeneity to the
Dynamics and things like missing data
under unreliable reporting rates
uh my colleague Alexander wolfowski is
already working on the network missing
this problem and I've been thinking a
lot on more realistic random graph
models for these Network Dynamics uh
we've been working on some things for
change Point detection when the force of
infection beta is also changing through
time again you don't want it to be too
flexible or else your model can fit
anything but so you want it to be
flexible enough but also parsimonious
enough so that you don't have volatile
predictions
and all sorts of things in particular
would want to really have hybrids right
we've I've overviewed all this kind of
work that I said this is complementary
to and I don't take issue with that kind
of work I just think that this this line
of work was somewhat abandoned for
because it was a hard math problem and
it was computationally intractable and
I'm saying that it's not necessarily
intractable if we're willing to think
hard about this but we can probably take
it even further by uh looking for these
connections explicitly with the other
things that people are doing in this
field many of which is also very
exciting methodology
so with that I'll wrap up I wanted to
thank especially the student
collaborators here I've mentioned fanbu
who was the lead author on this uh
Network paper and she's going to start a
faculty position at Michigan's biostats
Department we're very proud of her
Raphael is currently a PhD student
advised by me at Duke and is doing a lot
of the really exciting stuff on
computation for these fully missing data
settings and the semi-markovian settings
and Jenny Huang is an outstanding
undergraduate actually who is
unfortunately already committed to a PhD
program for those of you who might be in
the market to recruit Talent she's
joining mit's eecs program and she's
been working on a lot of the dynamic
change Point detection stuff for time
varying transmission rates under these
models so I'll just leave you with this
slide on some of the references a
partial list of references these papers
are under various pre-print statuses
submission statuses and publication
statuses and include my other
collaborators who are really wonderful
to work with throughout this whole
process so with that thank you very much
for uh for your time and for listening
Jason thank you you so much wow what an
interesting uh line of kind of attack on
this interesting challenging problem
um and I'm sure lots of people have
questions for you and I hope they can
ask them in the chat or maybe reach out
to you directly via email
um you mentioned
um exploring other multi-compartmental
kind of approaches can you describe a
few of what those might be and also what
does that do to some of the computations
some of the math and computation times
that might be involved
yeah that's a great question and so
there there's a couple different
directions and I'm going to mention two
of them so we talked about sort of uh I
guess it's on this last slide for things
like multiple strains and compartments
so one very natural thing I focused on
Sir here but there's of course ones with
more stages there's s-e-i-r where the
latent stage is is even harder to
observe so for these kinds of models
where there are more sequential stages
it's basically the challenge is to
design these proposals in a way that is
still identifiable so you can actually
explore the latent compartments in a way
that you can learn from the data because
you can't observe there's more that you
can't observe and so the mathematics
needs to change on the other hand when
it's simply sort of more levels like
maybe I have this identical model but I
have adults and children right and this
is this is a big thing right
epidemiologists care about how the
Dynamics with young people might be
different from different strata what I
would call strata in the age structure
other structure in the population and so
in those cases I would say a lot of the
mathematics goes through but then
computation is what's increasing in
complexity right you could imagine it's
not necessarily just double the
computation when you have double the
strata but because of the connections
between things and how you closet the
relationships it can grow even faster
than that in complexity so um there's
all sorts of these uh sort of trade-offs
to balance but I think it's absolutely
something that's worth investigating
right so this kind of heterogeneity you
can have for instance household
structure as well right you would have
two levels in a hierarchy where you have
this kind of network thing between
people then you also have household
units and their Dynamics so
um there's kind of going this way and
going this way in terms of expanding the
compartments and there's different
challenges that arise
one of the characteristics of
exponential distributions and sort of
embedded in Markov chain modeling is the
notion of memorylessness and some people
may not be familiar with that on what
that concept May mean mathematically and
what it means in the context of these
models would you mind doing as a solid
and explaining what that means
absolutely I barely mentioned that at
all and I think you know I'm trying to
tiptoe between too much technical
difficulty but like also I want to this
is actually a really important point
right so like I said these random models
they're they're processes so the time
between events has to follow some random
variable and the reason that people like
to choose exponentials is because
they're really mathematically convenient
they have this memorylessness which is
to say that let's say you know I person
one is uh sick in week one week two
they're still sick right the
memorylessness is saying that well when
I look at the mathematical properties
like the probability they recover at a
certain time I actually don't even need
to think about the fact that they were
already sick for a whole week okay and
that that of course makes the math
easier because otherwise I incur this
mathematical debt of having to remember
exactly when everybody got sick and
changing the probabilities based on how
long they've already been sick now on
the other hand now that I've revealed
that you could absolutely imagine why an
epidemiologist would say hey that's not
a really realistic assumption because
the expert Financial distribution
mathematically also has what's called
fat tails which means that there's a lot
of probability for the extreme events as
well so you could imagine well if every
time I'm like giving a fresh new coin
flip on whether this person is going to
recover if a particular person happens
to have you know uh survived for three
weeks in a row and the recovery period
tends to be much shorter than that this
is a really unlikely event so the model
is kind of giving Mass probability Mass
to something that's unrealistic
biologically so many people want to have
distributions that are more realistic
that have a memory property that says
well this person hasn't recovered yet
but already been sick for two weeks so
they're probably they recover is soon is
very high the exponential one that
probability doesn't change over time
which helps us mathematically but is not
that realistic like I said we have new
work that actually addresses this very
flexibly but is not focused on here
today that's a great question thank you
you mentioned uh also that um some of
the Assumption about that exponentiality
is may not be always true
um are there any other shapes of
distributions
um you know shape I guess a kind of
morphometry of other distributions which
might be suitable for the modeling may
have memoryless processes
um or maybe just you know also
convenience for a variety of reasons
yeah that's also a great question so I
mean in particular like I said we've
been developing methods for all sorts of
General processes with different what's
called renewal distributions but just
two that I'll mention you know something
that people have looked at in the past
is gamma distributions and the reason is
because statistically some Gammas have
multiple parameters but some members of
that family of distribution are actually
the the sum of exponentials so it's it's
kind of a very natural extension well
you could imagine that this is a larger
class
um and another thing that we've been
working with is the class of viable
distributions and that has some uh some
nice ramifications from extreme value
Theory which makes things more robust
um so there's all sorts of different
choices here and we've we've only
investigated a couple so far but the
methodologies in general and I think
there's a lot of uh you know there's a
lot of nice again it's it's an
interesting Balancing Act between
finding things that are nice enough
mathematically but also Rich enough to
describe what's going on in a way that's
satisfying to people who actually deal
with the data right so mathematically we
would exponentials are on one end of
that spectrum because they're the nicest
one but they're just simply not
appropriate for many uh for instance
infectiousness distributions so I would
say a good starting point and something
that's been looked at in the literature
in different contexts are both the gamma
family and the Bible family
have you ever put any of these uh
simulations like in motion to try to so
I guess to say uh in silico create a
little community that have its yeah have
it you know a monkey with the
assumptions of mixing rates and that
sort of thing and then uh kind of watch
these probabilities
um play out sort of again in a little in
silico Petri dish does that make sense
absolutely it makes sense and we this is
something that we absolutely have done I
I didn't really go into it in this talk
uh it's in the paper I did mention
though that there was a simulation study
where we validate the equations but
basically the way that works is that we
specify the Dynamics the probability
laws of the model and we do simulate a
little outbreak according to those rules
and then let's say we would hold out we
would pretend that we didn't simulate it
and know everything so we would now say
oh I'm only gonna I'm gonna throw away
all the data that I get to see except
for the same sort of quantities I would
see in an observational study and that's
super important to you know then employ
the a methodology we developed on that
setting where we're artificially only
giving ourselves access to some data but
we're seeing how well we can learn the
rest right so so we've done all sorts of
studies like that in the paper but to
another part of the question the
interesting thing is like I said you can
you can you can validate whether the
inference is correct under the model you
specify but a sort of related challenge
is well how can you simulate things well
for unobserved quantities so I guess
what I'm thinking of is you know in our
case we fully observe the mobile contact
Network and so we can we can learn the
rates and look at how that affects the
Transmissions but now let's say this is
something I again didn't go into but at
the end I said what if we could look at
more realistic random graph models and
what I mean by that is you know if you
now have a setting where you want some
Network to describe Behavior but you're
in a setting where you don't have for
instance a cell phone study so you don't
observe the network and now you want to
simulate that Network like you're
suggesting
um in a way that's plausible that might
explain the way people are are moving
even though you don't observe it right
so right in in our in our methodology we
have motivated how we don't observe the
recovery times but we're able to infer
them this is sort of an even harder
problem where you don't observe the
networks but you like to posit a model
that you can simulate potential networks
and so that can be hard because a lot of
times the the nice map again the nice
mathematical models many of them might
not reflect some things you tend to
observe in real life so you might have a
certain class of models You observe and
find there's like edges that are added
and removed but then many of the
observed networks don't have as many
triangles as you would see because in
real life my friend of a friend is more
likely to be a friend here and then if
you tweak it by adding you know closing
triangles when you have two friends but
then their friends of friends aren't
friends yet that could introduce new
triangles so there's all sorts of things
that have been you know persistent
problems in the literature that are
interesting fastest to think about when
you do simulation
yeah
um um
so some of your equations have probably
struck fear Into the Heart of several of
the biologists who are watching today
um what sort of
comment would you have for them about
wanting to participate in activities
that are like like this right what what
would they get out of doing something
like this as somebody who is a you know
card carrying biologist for example
yeah that's a great question too I think
it's um part of it the the difference in
things like interpretability and what I
keep saying the uncertainty
quantification I think that difference
is a little bit subtle but it's it's
it's something that I think biologists
would absolutely care about which is for
instance if I have a deterministic model
where the curve is governed by the
parameters like I said when you observe
counts it's never going to pass
perfectly through that deterministic
curve so what a lot of approaches do
that fit the model to data is they have
that curve plus just some probability
distribution like uh I have that mean
that curve describes the mean number of
infections but then I have either
gaussian or binomial measurements from
that curve and that amount of noise from
those distributions allows me to have at
least a likelihood of my data that's not
zero right it can be explained it's like
oh it didn't match this curve but
because I've only observed a noisy
version so now if I'm a biologist and
I'm you know plugging this into maybe
statistical software where I don't have
to look at these scary equations
confidence intervals out of it well what
does the confidence interval mean the
only probability in that model I just
described is coming from the measurement
error because I had a completely
deterministic process for the disease
and then the probabilities are on the
measurements of how I observe that fixed
curve so you have to kind of think it's
a little bit subtle but it's like all
the uncertainty can be interpreted as my
measurement uncertainty of a process
that's fixed okay so then when you
observe when you estimate beta and then
you have a confidence interval it's just
measurement error on beta that's you
know it's not saying that if I have a
quantity like I said in these models if
R naught is beta over gamma basically
normalized by the population
I I can't think of this as a statistical
average if beta and gamma are things
corresponding to a fixed curve and I
have to think about it as some other
thing that now has uncertainty around
how it was measured whereas in these
stochastic models which you do run into
these equations this is a much more
natural quantity because it's describing
the uncertainty in the random process
right because I'm now envisioning the
disease spread itself as a random
process I think that's extremely
important and I don't think that it's
always a bad idea to use deterministic
models but I do think it's important to
know how to interpret the uncertainty
coming out of your inference
and so my my the really the only way to
tell people to please look at these
equations is to say well look how
important it is in sort of the
repercussions of of knowing what model
you're working with right and then if I
had to just ease the notation I would
ease the equations themselves I would
just say that you got to trust that even
though there's a lot of notation these
things are nice like if I give notation
condensed things these equations can be
derived pen and paper in a couple
minutes and furthermore the whole idea
is that there's a lot of bookkeeping
when I write that exact same equation in
a specific instance for instance in our
model but even though these equations do
look daunting like they really are
things where if I have the bookkeeping
to like look at these quantities from
the data I could I could write down
these commands in r in a couple of
minutes right I could just put them in
and we did the math so that you can put
in the equations and furthermore we'd
hope to make this even more General we
have user-friendly software as long as
it's the high level like PD is clear
which is that there's a stochastic
process model and the inference for the
probabilistic quantification corresponds
to the uncertainty in the process itself
I hope that is a little bit long-winded
but I hope it makes sense it does thank
you Jason Jason this was really
wonderful thank you for sharing this uh
amazing amount of work with us uh it
looks very exciting and uh it's very
mathematically sophisticated
um and I'm sure that uh with a little
bit of of uh practice and some tutelage
even our biologists will be able to kind
of come to grips with it uh it's it's
really wonderful stuff and thank you for
sharing these references as well
um and kudos to you and to your
colleagues for uh putting this together
so um with that Jason thank you once
again thank you everybody who joined us
and everyone have a wonderful weekend
and uh we'll talk to you next week thank
you so much thanks for having me again
thank you Jason